again you see it it's a just an ordinary
car a belated field trip by three of
europe's top leaders to ukraine's former
front line
germany's chancellor somber
so too behind him the prime minister of
italy and president of france
this was once a nursery no more
surrounded by armed guards and
journalists they learnt about the horror
russia's war unleashed on the town of
urpin outside kiev
then it was on to meet the president
olaf schultz armed with a briefcase
there's been friction between these two
over what ukraine sees as german
sluggishness at gifting weapons and its
stance on russia
next came emmanuel macron
warmly embraced and with the longest of
handshakes
despite mistrust here too
over how far he may want ukraine to
compromise with russia to end the war
the visitors didn't come empty-handed
pledging support for ukraine to receive
candidate status to join the eu
a significant move that will anger
russia
they're giving military support too
but with the war still raging in the
east the german leader warned any
prospect for peace was still very far
away
so it is clear for me as the french
president mentions it must be made clear
to russia that it can't push through a
dictated peace that it won't succeed in
dictating ukraine's conditions that
can't be accepted either by ukraine or
by us
this united front also on display at a
meeting of nato defense ministers in
brussels
allies are offering more weapons to help
ukraine in its fight but will it be
enough to win
britain's defense secretary seems to
think so
i think ukrainians have
and will have in the next few weeks
the capabilities in their hands to make
significant progress in the east of the
country
optimistic language and it's clearly the
goal but ukraine is losing around 100
fighters a day to russian fire russian
artillery outnumbers ukraine's 20 to one
in places
what western allies here at nato are
hoping is that their weapons while fewer
in quantity can be more effective
against russia's if used correctly
for now in eastern ukraine russian
weapons are still dominating
moscow will be doing all it can to
exploit this advantage before the west's
deadlier guns start firing back
debra haynes sky news brussels